what's the deal with airplane peanuts
the alleys were the first people i ever
met ever
beside my godfather that ever spoke to
me about sex
and then i had this puerto rican dude on
my block puerto rican nelson
he lived in the back he was a bartender
in the city he used to always ask me
and he wasn't a freak or nothing i
always thought that at one point he
would molest me
yeah and even till today i think deep
sometimes [ __ ] puerto rican nelson
molest me because he used to always have
a robot and slippers and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's how he walked around oh my god
puerto rican nelson
something you're not sure if he did you
feel like it's maybe
yeah like i think that he ever doped me
like he would pull the car behind me
because
everything about him fits like an m.o he
was just a good dude yeah
that we used to go outside and help us
fix our bike
and he was a spanish dude he was just
you know he had the sideburns and the
leather jacket
and it was the [ __ ] early 70s and i
moved to jersey
and he would talk to a bunch of us and
one day he would take us in the back
his claim to fame with me was that i
became friends with him
and i go over there and he had a black
friend uh that
went over to the rock of gibraltar and
he brought pictures back
and then he would just talk to me then
one day he asked me to meet him
[Applause]
you got a couple of people go to
somebody's house and you go to the house
a lot and they're sober
but one day you catch them in their
[ __ ] hammond
yeah and we go over there and it's like
early in the morning like i used to go
over there every morning at 10
and wake him up and and what's up man
what are we gonna do today
give me an hour i'll go out there and
play stick ball with you and he came out
with coffee and he wreaked of alcohol
you know he was one of those dudes in
the summer
you know no air conditioning airport
just a dynamite dude yeah
and one day i knock on the door and he
answers with a towel around him and he
sits down like he's all [ __ ] up like
well nelson you're gonna play football
he's like man
not today you know and all this [ __ ] he
goes come back in like two hours so
you know we in those days you're
punctual yeah like we were there in two
hours
he has it though you guys again the
[ __ ] curtains were still up
he invites us in he's got a towel on you
know
he turns the light on and there's like a
table filled with alcohol
you know and like oh yeah how old are
you at this point 12
12 and i can't remember who the [ __ ] i
walked in there with like
it was like six of us in the
neighborhood that liked nelson
but two of us actually interacted a
little closer with nelson yeah
i was spanish so i understood nelson's
world i knew puerto rican people
but i can't believe who else was the
other guy
that mingled with nelson so we had woken
nelson up
he goes come on come here we sign his
couch you guys want a soda he gives us a
certain
he puts the tv on you can see he's still
[ __ ] up from the night before
he's got the towel on and he's like so
you guys get late
and we don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about like nobody ever spoke to
me like that
i had uncles that would ask me how
anybody suck your dick yet
yeah are you pissing sweet yet that type
of [ __ ] but this
oh yeah yeah when you're spanish
you know what i'm saying a great line
but nelson was basically the first
person ever but like
i ain't known about sex but nelson was
the first person ever that said
it could be yours you know it's like
like what do you mean you never had sex
i got a girl right now she'll come over
and clean your pipe you're gonna be like
and we're both like [ __ ] [ __ ] not
pants
yeah you come up with like ten dollars
like nah nah nah
so that was he never talked about it
again and then when they were sitting
there like a [ __ ]
just saw this guy like a guy in a
[ __ ] towel
as neighborhood boys over and offers to
get them all over
and he's drunk because he's outrageous
they haven't had sex at 14 or 12.
so he was cool as [ __ ] he used to play
bad basketball with us
and [ __ ] so one day i go away with this
kid
and he starts telling us what's his name
again puerto rican nelson
is it big capitalized no was
because he used to bring us weed from
the city
and he would actually give us seven
joints for five dollars wow
he really took care of us it wasn't like
he was a bad guy which
to me meant the world because a lot of
people could bring your weed over in
those days but they say i take a joint
off the top
he was like i gotta go over anyway don't
worry about it
the guy gives me a better deal so i
always liked him because of that
so one day we're there and like the
girls there
a girl comes out of his bedroom me and
my buddy like wow
look at puerto rican now someone abroad
she sits on his lap and [ __ ]
and he's like yeah this is my girl he's
feeling her up and he's making that in
front of her
and it to these issues
and me and my buddy are frozen like
we're just i can feel
i can i can't remember who the [ __ ] it
was
so how old was this guy this guy had to
be 28 and the bro was like 21.
but he was he was one of those he had to
be 26 maybe
he was from somewhere else and he lived
there just before the computer before
neighborhood watching before
and no one was freaked out by a pack of
12 year olds hanging out with them
no because in those days a lot of
parents came out and played with kids
i know that's different now see if this
would never be able to play with a
random guy no no so everybody knew him
for the neighborhood and in those days
we wanted to go into the murky waters
yeah
and he was kind of opening the door not
really to be honest here
it took a long time it's not like he
liked us into his house
and said do you guys want to have sex
this is after we knew him for a year
right we go back there all the time to
get one after a basketball game
we know him you know but now he knew we
were growing up and he knew what our
needs were
i look at it now like he was he was just
trying to but we couldn't handle it
yeah so one day was sitting back that we
had a basketball game
and he's like hey man what'd you think
of that [ __ ] broad the other day me
and my buddy like oh
she was banging he goes i'll tell you
what he goes tell these guys how hot she
was
and me and my buddy's like yeah she was
hot he's like oh when can we see it
he goes listen i'll tell you what i'm
gonna do
he just listen i'm gonna [ __ ] her
tonight in the living room
and i'll leave the window open you guys
can come by and listen
well you know how many times i got an
audition i hear this like my this is my
a lot of people don't like to audition i
like to audition
and i tell you why because i [ __ ] with
them because you're funny you know i've
ripped my pants out you know
if you watch uh uh what's that show on
cbs that's been on forever
i don't know which one monday nights the
one before that
how i met your mother i did however you
know i got how i met your mother
i didn't even know you did it yeah if
you watched the episode you're like joey
you're an extra
i'm an extra you know why because i went
into the audition i had no underwear on
and there was this you see these things
that pop out of chairs
yeah the side things the way you move
your armrest right and she goes get up
to read when i when i got up to read
the [ __ ] thing got caught in the hole
in my pants and my dick came out
all three women sat there and i go did
you see the egg roll and then i lost
them for sure
they even told me they go you got the
job as i was walking down the street on
fox my phone rang my engine goes go back
you didn't even read
i didn't even read and they called my
agent said we love this guy i went back
and when i went they didn't even read
they saw the cube and they grow you know
well they were probably not used to
someone with confidence that didn't give
a [ __ ] you know i went to an audition
one time bro where
the guy had i'll never forget this the
guy was a white trash guy like this
family moved in it was a pilot for abc
and this guy is one of those guys that
uh he had a little circular pool in
front of his house
and he was he was watering [ __ ] but at
the same time he had like a thong on
and he's fat he's got jewelry on like
one of those guys in like long island
you know what i'm saying
so i never forget i get to the audition
all these guys are there tony longo got
rested saw all these big italian dudes
and i knew they were going to get the
part bro i'm like they're going to get
the part i'm not going to get it but i
had warm ups on it
all right i had warm-ups on with the
string and i had white
tighty whities and i had a zip up jacket
and i had to weigh 380.
so i walked in i go i know what i'm
going to do i'm going to take my pants
off
all right i'm taking my [ __ ] sweats
off
what do you think these two ladies say
to me hold on one second we'll be bit
with you in a minute
so they turn around that's my cue
[ __ ] i took those sweatpants off i took
the shoes off in my socks and i walked
closer
and i took my shirt off when they turned
back around
all i had was boxing shorts on like the
tiny whities
that's it ted's hanging out stomach
hanging over the underwear
and then they did as soon as they turned
on they're like oh my god
they're like that is terrible put your
shirt back on i'm like i'm not putting
on [ __ ] all right i'm reading this
[ __ ] how it is
so you were supposed to like wave and
say good morning
and then like action and they're like
can't even look at me because i'm
completely naked
you know and then they can't even look
at me and i make them believe i'm
flipping burgers and i look over at them
like oh
living like a doctor that's it they
booked me
when i got to the audition it's that was
the read living like a doctor they even
gave my own line
half of those auditions i went into they
gave me whatever line i said in the
audition
like whatever they said wasn't good
enough i got going there with my own
[ __ ] line
yeah that's that's probably why you got
it look at this
look look at joey he's just sitting
there that's when you were in those big
daddy shirts yeah look how big i was
jesus christ you were enormous back then
those that must have been like what two
thousand then right
yeah this is two thousand two thousand
two
i remember when i when i met you like
right after i met you i brought you onto
the set of news radio
and then they were all like um who is
this guy
which is a jacket on is this guy your
friend like
that's joey
the kids on 148th street were puerto
rican
irish italian a couple
jews and all of them were tough but
we're talking same age range and
everything same
age before i got into santeria
my mom would send me up to my
godmother's house on 148th street
and broadway 20 blocks from the
epicenter of the world
harlem you have 20 blocks from harlem
yeah i was the heartbeat of new york
city
i'm 20 blocks in the heart of new york
city six
five oh wow so i'm hanging out down
there on 88th street playing buck buck
and killing rats
148th street coming
complete different game first down 148
they came up to me how you doing
ricky whatever and awesome they're like
what do you want to do i don't know i
play stickball and they're like nah you
want to see a body
i'm like what are you talking about
let's go see a dead body
i'm like i like these kids they took me
down to west side avenue
and they had some guy who had been hit
by a car this is the 70s this is like 65
there was no csi if you got hit by a car
you were there for like two or three
days you saw
that your first dead body first dead
body i saw
he was already had the flies on him and
they just threw plywood over him
and he was starting to stink like from
10 feet away
like he had just been there maybe like
like these kids were he was right by the
hudson river
and we would walk down to the hudson
river and then finally two days later we
went down there was a crime scene
obviously some [ __ ]
you know in those days people didn't jog
it's not like today that there's jogging
yeah i can kill you
kill you and drop you on a 170 they
never find you
today these [ __ ] joggers they're out
there looking around
and they always find bodies joggers it's
not like they find like a twenty dollar
bill you never seen a jogger though
i found an envelope full of money they
always find some lady beat up and raped
what the [ __ ] kind of morning is that
[Laughter]
oh my god oh [ __ ] we're only at
six how all this were only at
six and then one day
i transferred from [ __ ] catholic
school got thrown out and i went to
mckinley
and now i had to go to school with john
and all those other kids in that area
and it was not hard for me i can't lie
to you it wasn't hard for me i'm
i knew them already excuse me i knew
half of them
already from the neighborhood so in the
sixth grade
i [ __ ] went to the courts like i did
every day and i'm playing basketball
because i want to be good at basketball
okay and this kid richie ferreira
wants to play basketball so we're
playing basketball and he's kind of
drunk
now i'm [ __ ] 12 you know maybe 11
12. richie forever is maybe 17.
so [ __ ] in the middle of the game i
said richie stop following us he pushes
me he throws the ball down the [ __ ]
hill
i get up to push him he just knocks the
[ __ ] out of me
and i i didn't cry nothing i just
took it and went down to the corner and
went and picked up the [ __ ] ball and
went home
but my pants are ripped i tell the story
on stage
not the extended version but this all
went down and carmine was on his porch
with peter looking at this this was a
commotion
and the next thing you [ __ ] know i go
home and i go in the shower my mom's
home what the [ __ ] is my mom doing am i
going to shower
the phone always rings if my mom is home
so i don't
but the next day is when when i got home
and she said listen we're going to go to
the park you got beat up yesterday you
didn't do nothing
and i'm like mom what the [ __ ] so she's
taking me to the park
she takes the guy we fight he beats me
up again my mom walks me home tells me
it's okay
i'm gonna get into a lot of brawls in my
life
but guess what richie ferrara does
what he hires john bender to fight me
what so i'm in the sixth grade one day
and john bender comes and he goes hey
[ __ ] oh spec whatever we're fighting at
three today
you richie ferrara how old was
john sixth great we're both the same age
what both the same age so now i go home
i take my books out now this was big
time
this was weird because they thought
calmly was gonna come
so bobby got on the corner they had
people on top of the hill
and john showed up with every white kid
in town you know i'm standing there with
[ __ ] martin perez
valentin pharaoh dominic speciale and
michael special
you know he showed up with 15 [ __ ]
kids
and they made a circle and i fought him
and he broke my nose
and i gave him a black eye and he busted
my lip he really beat me up if you want
to know the truth
and the next day we just went to school
like nothing happened
and then like a week late he comes up to
me and he goes listen what happened
i feel really bad and he shook my hand
and i took it for what it was i always
knew something was going to happen
between us one day where i'd stab
him or something i wasn't saying nothing
you